in a dramatic escalation of the crisis
over ukraine u.s president joe biden
says he's sending 3000 troops to
strengthen the american presence in
eastern europe and to reassure nato
allies of america's commitment to
collective defense the pentagon
emphasizing it is not sending troops to
ukraine but adding today's announcement
is meant to deter russian president
vladimir putin from invading ukraine the
kremlin has already denounced the move
as destructive saying it's likely only
to increase tensions
another day another increase in tension
over ukraine
the u.s is sending two thousand soldiers
to poland and germany while another
thousand move from germany to romania
the current situation demands that we
reinforce the deterrent and defensive
posture on nato's eastern flank
president biden has been clear
that the united states will respond to
the growing threat to europe's security
and stability
our commitment to nato article 5 and
collective defense remains ironclad
the pentagon made it clear that no u.s
soldiers will fight in ukraine ukrainian
president vladimir zelinsky said
diplomacy comes first but no options are
off the table
we only think about peace we only think
about the return of our occupied
territories and only through diplomacy
despite zelinski's reassurances others
are preparing to do battle if it comes
to a fight
the klitschko boxing brothers one now
the mayor of kiev both signed up for the
the west are army into question we are
not weak
and any aggressor have to understand
if they do it activity aggressive
activity against ukraine
they have to pay huge price for that
we're ready to fight
leaked documents confirmed by the
pentagon reveal the backroom diplomatic
efforts to avoid war
the u.s offered russia access to inspect
key military sites in return for a
de-escalation
russia says it has no intention to
invade ukraine
but these pictures released by russia's
defense ministry showing joint combat
drills with belarus send a clear message
russia is not backing down
all right we've got team coverage of
this development tonight i want to bring
in our very own oliver salad he's in
washington and nick connolly is covering
events for us in kiev in ukraine to you
both it's good to see you oliver let me
start with you
why this deployment now i mean has the
security situation changed or are we
talking about
purely symbolic moves here
yeah it's a bit of both brand really the
pentagon spokesperson uh john kirby
earlier said that it's a response to
that russian troop built up that we're
seeing we saw satellite pictures earlier
today um showing that russia continues
to add forces to belarus and of course
to that border region between russia and
the ukraine and that's a concern of
course for the united states for its
nato allies as well and that is met now
with a troop built up of the united
states but of course in a very much
smaller scale and therefore yes in part
it's also a symbolic move given that 60
000 u.s troops are already stationed in
europe a hundred thousand russian
soldiers on the other side of the border
and 3 000 u.s troops is really not big
of a number that we're seeing here
sent and deployed by the united states
and nick the pentagon spokesman today
made it clear that the u.s is not
sending any additional troops to ukraine
so what does today's announcement mean
then
for the situation on the ground there
well i think it just shows to ukrainians
once again what the value of nato
membership is um the numbers in ukraine
for nato membership were not
particularly high before russia and x
crimea back in 2018 started that
separatist campaign in the east and you
ukraine basically has been convinced by
vladimir putin over the last eight years
that this is an alliance worth being in
and that it makes a difference being
outside
um the block um i think the ukrainians
have been happy to see u.s deliveries of
ammunition of weapons system those
javelin anti-tank missiles in recent
weeks from the us also from the uk but
beyond that the ukrainians are now very
clear that apart from weapons and cash
they're on their own and you know in the
short-term medium term they'll have to
stand up to russia on their own without
boots on the ground from the us or other
western allies and you know all they can
do at this point is hope that this
passes for now and that at some point uh
russia will
be distracted and they will be able to
join nato or some other alliance that
puts them in a more comfortable position
and oliver as it stands right now we
know that 8 500 troops are
on high alert in the u.s for a possible
deployment now we've got 3 000 that we
know are going to eastern
europe do we know exactly how long
they're going to be stationed there
well the official take is it's just a
temporary deployment of course we don't
know for how long because what the us
eventually wants to reach is an
agreement following the diplomatic
effort that we've been seeing over the
last weeks but of course that implies
that putin de-escalates that he changes
course that he drops his maximum demands
that we've heard
and that are of course russia wants to
ban the ukraine from joining nato
something that nato won't accept so we
are really very much in a stalemate here
right now and it doesn't look like uh
things are getting clearer as we speak
we're looking at that russian troop
built up so it's rather likely that we
are seeing the tensions getting more
severe
before we see any kind of de-escalation
oliver salad reporting tonight from
washington nick connolly with the latest
from keeve to both of you gentlemen
thank you
and we want to take this story now to
poland i'm joined now by radoslav fogiel
he's a member of the polish parliament
for the governing law and justice party
he joins me tonight from warsaw it's
good to have you on the program let's
just talk about numbers for a moment
here a thousand troops going to poland
from the united states is that just a
drop in the bucket for you
good evening it's a pleasure to and to
be with you no it's not it's not a drop
it's
extremely important from our point of
view from the point of view of
our
central european allies
it shows the unity and strength of nato
the strengthening of eastern flank in
this situation is extremely important we
have
diplomatic talks
[Music]
on one side but on the other side the
ability the deterrence ability of
of western allies is
extremely extremely important
the u.s says that these troops will not
be going to fight in ukraine
but in your opinion is this the right
time
to be sending troops to to eastern
europe i mean there there is the
possibility that that these moves could
escalate instead of stabilize or
de-escalate do you agree
i don't agree at all
and i would say
there
is no better time than
right now
for for uh strengthening american
presence on on the ground here
in in europe because we cannot
let us being taken hostage by the
russians by
by putin's propaganda and and putting
his aggressive
policy we have to show our strength we
have to
show our decisiveness and
we cannot as the west as the alliance we
cannot be
backing off all the
time the nato policy of open doors is
something that all
alliance members agree on
and we have to send a very clear message
to the kremlin that
ukraine's right to determine determine
its future to
have its territory
complete and and
free from any aggression is is the key
to proper relationships the
relationships between russia and and the
west
and we know mr fogel that russia does
not see it that way we have the illegal
annexation of crimea as one example
to prove that
i know your your country shares a border
with ukraine
how big is the concern or the fear that
if russia were to invade ukraine that
that military conflict could then spill
over
into poland
we share a border not only with ukraine
but with russia itself as well but most
importantly
we share hundreds of years of history
with
russia in its different forms so we can
we can talk
from our experience that this
imperialistic politics will be
followed by by
russian government
uh
till it uh it stops
until it is stopped by
by a very strong western response we all
hoped for de-escalation
but
a show of strength and the ability to
to respond is also extremely important
when it comes to
to the
the escalation possibilities i still
hope
uh that
this is just a power play from uh from
flaming vladimir putin and that he won't
he won't attack ukraine but in this case
in this case
well
i don't i don't
think poland would be threatened
directly but
our concerns the concerns of all the
baltic states
are
real because it may seem very different
from uh paris berlin or washington
perspective but
right here
on on this par in this part of europe
the
the the russian threat is
israel
yeah and that's why it's very important
that we hear views coming from countries
such as poland radislav foghill member
of the polish parliament for the
governing law and justice party mr
folger we appreciate your time and your
insights tonight thank you
thank you very much
joining us now is rodriguez he sits in
the german parliament for the opposition
party the christian democrats and is a
member of the bundestag foreign affairs
committee very warm welcome to dw news
sir um now as you've heard the u.s says
these troops that will be deployed this
week will not be fighting in ukraine but
in your assessment is this the right
moment to be deploying us troops to
germany
well i believe this is a strong symbol
to the european allies it's a moderate
and deliberate step and it should
encourage european partners to stand
together and as a symbol for
cohesiveness it's less a sign towards
russia it's a sign of solidarity to the
european uh nato member states and i
think this is a good sign it's moderate
it's deliberate it's not escalatory
but how do you think it will be
perceived by the kremlin i mean the u.s
state department has talked about the
need for de-escalation with this
deployment does it risk escalating
tensions
no we should ask russia why they deploy
more than 100 000 troops and by the end
of february more than 150 000 troops
about 60 of their armed land forces this
is escalatory and it's quite clear that
we europeans are
really nervous and we see this as an
escalation without any need russia has
breached the budapest memorandum ukraine
has handed over more than 20 years ago
its nuclear weapons and now it loses
sovereignty and territorial integrity so
we europeans must stand together and
it's a sign of solidarity to from the
united states to us europeans it's not
escalatory to russia we should ask
russia why do you escalate at the
ukrainian border
are you worried that germany could
become a kind of a launch pad for any
military activity if the security
situation in ukraine deteriorates
germany has a task and a mission and we
should stand together with our allies
and germany has received security for
more than four decades uh within nato
and now we should become a security
provider so i really i'm grateful for
this american
engagement three years ago with trump
this was imaginable
and so we see that biden fosters the
transatlantic relationship and germany
must play a role in it
to that uh answer is it time that
germany steps up to the plate and does
itself more to support ukraine
militarily
well germany
has quite empty stock files regarding
ammunition and other equipment so we
should reconsider a reform of our armed
forces and we should become more
reliable in encouraging and
supporting our eastern neighbors and
what is also at stake is to improve
diplomacy
so i am really
grateful for the foreign minister that
she traveled to
russia and to ukraine and i ask
olaf schultz the chancellor not only to
travel to washington but also to ukraine
to kiev and that we become a strong
european voice
which is also listened to by putin we
europeans need a stronger own commitment
so that not putin and biden negotiate uh
about the security and future of europe
we really need uh to take over the uh us
offer for uh
for a stronger european force and the
european defense and we should take care
and invest more in our own security and
there is germany really um uh in the
forefront to improve its own security
in conclusion sir to fulfill its
commitments to fulfill its commitments
to that end as well and in conclusion my
final question to you
is is there anything that germany can do
to offer the russian president a
president of vladimir putin so he can
climb down from this situation without
losing face
i believe it's not up to germany to do
this it's up to putin but what we need
is that putin declares the exercise as
ended and he declares this escalation as
an exercise this would be helpful on the
other side
we need a new negotiations about
conventional and nuclear troop
reductions we need trust building
measures we need a new system of
armaments control i believe this could
be if the crisis is overcome i hope so
that then we start a new negotiation
agreement on conventional disarmament in
europe
is a lawmaker in the german parliament
for the opposition party the christian
democrats and he's also a member of the
bundestag foreign affairs committee sir
thank you so much for taking out the
time to speak to us appreciate it thank
you good evening